This episode is sponsored by 80,000 Hours. 80,000
Hours is a nonprofit that aims to help people have
a positive impact with their career. Head to
80000hours.org/microcosmos to start planning
a career that could potentially help solve
one of the world’s most pressing problems.
What you’re watching right now is something that
James, our master of microscopes, had never seen
before. And given how much of the microcosmos he’s
watched, anything that’s new to him is thrilling
to us. What he’d found were those two Loxodes
you see stuck together, waltzing around in a
very public display of conjugation. While
there are ciliates that frequently dally around
in sexual reproduction, for others—including
these Loxodes—it’s just not a common sight.
So James kept his camera focused
on them, following their progress.
But in the process of watching this population of
Loxodes, James would find something much stranger
going on in the microcosmos. Something
that would start innocently enough,
but that would end up in a place
far darker than he had anticipated.
The scene in front of you now is filled with
loxodes, more of those freshwater ciliates
we were just watching. The smaller
species are called Loxodes striatus,
and the larger ones are called Loxodes magnus.
And that’s what we’re following around right now,
a Loxodes magnus navigating a field
of debris and other organisms.
But why? In a screen full of these
organisms, why are we following this one?
Well, this Loxodes magnus is large—so
large that it was able to eat a rotifer,
those funny animals we often see getting
bullied by their single-celled neighbors.
And James meant to quickly capture another one of
those instances before moving on. As the Loxodes
turns, you can sometimes see the outline of the
rotifer taking up space in grayish oval area.
But what James realized as he was watching—and
maybe you’ve caught on to this as well
thatrotifer is moving. It’s alive,
twisting and turning inside of
the food vacuole it’s been stuffed into.
And when James realized that, he had to keep
recording. Because there are stories out there
of rotifers fighting back. Of them stretching
themselves and piercing away at the ciliate
that had the gall to eat them until finally,
they poke through the body that’s attempting to
digest them and escape. So yeah, James wanted to
see if he could watch that happen, to see if
he could watch the rotifer triumph for once.
If only it were that easy. But that’s getting
ahead of ourselves. Let’s just sit here for a
bit and watch the rotifer at work. This is one
of those episodes where I’ll be quiet for a bit
and then chime in as the rotifer’s journey takes
shape. And for now, the story is straightforward.
The rotifer It tumbles and stretches, and
the shape of its captor shifts in response,
expanding in width as the
rotifer refuses to be digested.
If it seems like the rotifer is
sometimes putting up less of a fight,
you’ll have to excuse it. The conditions it
is facing inside the Loxodes’ food vacuole are
intense, a bath of acid meant to eat away at its
body and render all its multicellular complexity
into a well-digested stew. The fact that it has
survived this long seems like a small miracle.
At this point, the Loxodes is passing alongside a
field of rotifers—the sisters of the very rotifer
the Loxodes is trying to digest, And you can
see them making that same telescoping motion
as their trapped sibling, just from the
anchored safety of a piece of debris.
Perhaps it seems like the rotifer is making
all this movement for nothing, but just wait…
This. This is the moment where
the rotifer’s escape begins in
earnest. It managed to tear a chunk out of
the Loxodes, ripping out an escape route
that the rotifer’s head
can start to peek out of.
Just watch as it keeps that movement going, the
gaping hole in the loxodes growing larger and
larger as the rotifer continues its
work. The Loxodes seems unperturbed,
continuing to swim as if its insides aren’t being
torn apart. But with enough time and enough poking
and prodding, the rotifer escapes its acid prison,
making its way once more into the microcosmos.
This is a moment to celebrate, right? We’ve
been watching this rotifer try and try
and try for minutes, and here we are now,
with all the success to show for it as it
sets up a new home for itself.
That’s what James thought too,
except that he quickly realized that something was
wrong. The rotifer wasn’t alone. It was actually
inside another rotifer, or rather what had once
been a rotifer—what had once been its mother.
The acids of the Loxodes’ food vacuole had eaten
her body away, digesting and decomposing it
until all that was left was an exoskeleton that
protected the young rotifer living within her.
While rotifers hatch from eggs, there are
species that hatch from eggs that are still
tucked away inside of their mothers.
This trait is called ovoviviparity,
and it’s found in various amphibians, insects,
and sharks…and yes, rotifers like this one,
using their body to shield their young.
And yes, the young rotifer survived.
But as James watched, a more cruel truth emerged:
the young rotifer was stuck. The same cuticle
that had protected the rotifer from the acids
of the loxodes would now hold it forever,
rigid and uncaring to its former
life as that rotifer’s mother.
The next day confirmed the valiant
young rotifer’s tragic end,
stuck within the confines of its mother’s cuticle
there towards the bottom of your screen, no longer
pushing and shoving, but motionless in death.
And as for the Loxodes, we don’t know
what happened to it. But given the
capacity of its family for regeneration,
it probably survived with little injury.
Perhaps it swam by its former meal,
unaware of their previous encounter
a battle waged, a battle lost, and the world
moving on around them both just the same.
Thank you for coming on this journey with us as
we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
And thank you again to 80,000 Hours
for sponsoring today’s episode.
80,000 Hours is a nonprofit that aims to help
people have a positive impact with their career.
The direction of your career path is a
big life decision and 80,000 hours has
a lot of free resources to help you plan and
research what options might be best for you.
They’ve got fantastic, free resources
including decision-making tools,
a constantly updated job board, and even a podcast
where they have in-depth conversations with
experts in the world’s most pressing problems,
and discuss what you can do to help solve them.
80,000 Hours wants to help you find a career
that does good in the world and all of their
provided resources are free! They’re a non-profit,
and their only aim is to help you
find a fulfilling, high-impact career.
Click our link in the description or go
to 80000hours.org/microcosmos to be sent a
free copy of their in-depth career guide to start
learning how you could have a high-impact career.
This will also sign you up for their newsletter,
where they send updates on their research
and high impact job opportunities
Before we go, we’d also like to thank all of
our patreon patrons, whose names you’re seeing
on the screen right now. If you’d like to help
support this channel so we can keep bringing
you bizarre stories like this one, you can
head on over to patreon.com/journeytomicro
If you’d like to see more from our
Master of Microscopes James Weiss,
you can check out Jam & Germs on Instagram
And if you’d like to see more from us, there’s
probably a subscribe button somewhere nearby.